el resurgimiento de casos de kobe 19
llega acompañado de un aumento de las
reivindicaciones las enfermeras y los
médicos protestaron frente al hospital
gregorio marañón de madrid en contra de
las autoridades locales a las que exigen
mayores recursos españa es el país con
más casos en europa superando ya el
medio millón y la inminente llegada de
la temporada invernal hace temer un
nuevo colapso en el sistema sanitario
es que va a colapsar tuvimos un mes de
marzo abril mayo que colapso por una
pandemia por un kobe pero el problema
ahora es de recursos humanos ya se nos
va a juntar el rebrote que sea mayor o
menor va a llegar con con la lista de
espera que espera ser atendida con un
problema humano el personal va a
enfermar si estamos así en el mes de
septiembre no queremos imaginar cómo
vamos a estar en el mes de diciembre que
es realmente la temporada alta de la
sanidad un informe del consejo de
supervisión de la preparación global un
órgano independiente lanzado por la
organización mundial de la salud y el
banco mundial denuncia que sus
advertencias fueron ignoradas
advertimos que el mundo estaba mal
preparado para tal pandemia trágicamente
y catastróficamente hemos visto
realizado en nuestro peor temor el
impacto del cob y 19 es aún peor de lo
que habíamos previsto pero las medidas
que pedimos el año pasado aún no se han
tomado sin esas medidas el mundo
permanece vulnerable
el panel advierte que si los gobiernos
no actúan una próxima pandemia no es
sólo inevitable sino que será aún más
devastadora la organización mundial de
la salud informó el domingo de un
aumento récord en un día de los casos de
kobe 19 en todo el mundo con un total de
más de 300.000 infecciones en 24 horas